السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
بتسمحوا لي بالبدايه
نحيي فريق العمل اللي هو عباره عن شباب
وطلاب جامعه وطلاب جامعه مؤته
واكيد عباده شغلنا الطلبه ومركز الرياده
وبصراحه
لما طلبوا مني الشباب اني احضر بخصوص كنت
افكر شو هي الاشي الممكن اشاركه معكم سواء
تجربه شخصيه معتقد قصه قراتها او اي شغله
ثانيه عشان هيك فكرت فيه اني احكي لكم انه
النجاح زي ما حكى الاستاذ رامي الدكتور
رامي انه النجاح اصبح لا يكفي
انه نكون ناجحين بهذه الحياه اصبح لا يكفي
ويا ترى ليش اصبح لا يكفي اصبح لا يكفي
لانه الانفتاح نحو لانا المنافسه الفرص
الكثيره اصبحت لا تكفي فقط انك تكون انسان
ناجح معناته شو لازم تكون برايكم شو لازم
تكون غير انسان ناجح او اكثر من انسان
ناجح
لازم تكون شخص متميز المطلوب حاليا منا
كلياتنا انه نكون اشخاص متميزين
التميز بحد ذاته اذا بندور على التعريف
اله راح نلاقي له العديد من التعاريف انا
شخصيا دائما بحب احط تعريف خاصه فيا اما
من تجربه شخصيه او اجين من قصه قراتها
استلهمت فيها معنى التميز او معنى الاشياء
اللي بصير حوليها وبصراحه هاي ميزه علمني
اياها والدي رحمه الله عليها
فمره ثانيه شو هو التميز التميز بوجهه
نظري الشخصيه هي عباره عن خطوه صغيره
خطوه صغيره بقوم فيها شخص مثابر مجتهد
وجاهز للمخاطره يجتاز فيه حاجز وهمي وضعت
الناس لانفسها وبيلهم الاخرين لاتباع هذا
الخطوات مره ثانيه التميز هي خطوه صغيره
مش بالضروره تكون اشي كثير كبير خطوه
صغيره بيكون فيها شخص مثابر ومجتهد جاهز
للمخاطره اجتاز فيه حاجز وهمي وضعتوا
الناس لانفسها وبخلي الاخرين بلهم الاخرين
لاتباع هاي الخطوات وبالمناسبه الخطوات
الصغيره
اللي كل مره بيجي اشخاص متميزين بخطوا
خطوه ثانيه هي اللي صنعت الحضاره هي اللي
خلت الدول تتطور هي خلت المجتمعات تتطور
هي خلت حتى المؤسسات القطاع الخاص القطاع
تتطور وبتساعد حتى الافراد انهم يتطوروا
عشان توصلكم الفكره اللي انا بدي احكي لكم
اياها قبل تقريبا اربع سنين وبدي اياك
تركزوا معي ليش قبل اربع سنين قبل اربع
سنين قرات قصه الهامتني كثير اثرت على
حياتي شخصيا واثرت على قرار العملي واثرت
على العملي بشكل خاص القصه هي اربع دقائق
تخيلوا انه لعام 1954 كان في اعتقاد طبي
انا بعرف انه هون في كثير دكاتره صح مزبوط
دكاتره يرفع ايديهم بالله
حلو فيش ولا دكتور بقدر اكذب زي ما بدي لا
بمزح معكم
لحد عام 1954 كان في هناك اعتقاد طبي بانه
الانسان لا يستطيع انه يتجاوز انه يركض
الميل باقل من اربع دقائق
هاي الحقيقه او هاي المعلومه الطبيه كانت
شبه حقيقه علميه وكان السبب باعتقاد
الاطباء انه قلب الانسان جسميا لا يستطيع
يتحمل الضغط راح يتعرض اما للانفجار او
التوقف فاي شخص راح يركض باقل من اربع
دقائق هذا الشخص معرض للايش معرض للموت
لحد عام 1954 سته سته خمسه قام عداء
مثابر مجتهد واخذ الرزق كان جاهز للمخاطره
اسمه روجر بنستر قام هذا العداء بقطع
مسافه ميل باقل من اربع دقائق
باعتقادكم قديش قطعوا باقل من اربع دقايق
الغريب بالموضوع انه هاي خطوه كانت كثير
صغيره
بس الهمت العديد من الاشخاص
قطع الميل بثلاث دقائق وتسعه وخمسين ثانيه
واربع اجزاء من الثانيه باقل حتى من
الثانيه
روجر خطر كان مثابر واثبت للناس كلياتها
انه الحاجز الوهمي اللي وضعناه لانفسنا ما
هو الا وهم انا مستعد اخذ خطوه صغيره
للامام وبدي افرجيكم اني انا بقدر اكون
متميز خطوه روجر الصغيره هاي والغريب
بقصته انه انهمت العديد من الاشخاص بعد
اقل من 6 اشهر ست اسابيع عفوا بعد اقل من
6 اسابيع قام عداء بريطاني ثاني بركض
مسافه النيل باقل من اربع دقائق وقطعها
بثلاث دقائق ب58 ثانيه تجاوز روجر
هاي الخطوات الصغيره اللي كل شوي بقطعوها
الاخرين وصلت انه الانسان قدر يركض الميل
باقل من ذلك بكثير
وافضل توقيت كان بالفعميه وتسعين
وبالمناسبه كان مغربي وكانت هي التوقيت
ثلاث دقائق وثلاثه واربعين ثانيه
روجر وقصته اللي قراتها كانت ملهمه كثير
بالنسبه لي وبصراحه انا بتذكر اني قراتها
كانت بمناسبه او كان السبب انه وفاته توفى
روجر بعام 2018
وهو بالمناسبه كمان هو طبيب ولما كان يركض
كان طبيب وتخصص بالاعصاب وكان طبيب متميز
وصار رئيس كليه ورئيس جامعه وغيره واملا
حياته بالتميز التحدي اللي كان او الفكره
اللي كانت عند رويجر انه الحواجز الوهميه
اللي وقف عليها الناس وصارت خط وحاجز
بيناتهم اقتنع انه بيقدر يخطو خطوه صغيره
للامام ويتجاوز هذا الاشي وهون التميز
تبعه
فعشان هيك النجاح اصبح لا يكفي
هاي القصه وانا بحضرها
استوقفت موقف صار معي تقريبا قالوا قبل
اقل من شهر بجامعه اليرموك كنت جزء من
المحاضرين او المتحدثين
ودكتور من الدكاتره الموجودين اذا قال لي
عمران القصص اللي بتحكيها للطلاب قديمه
مش واقعيه احكي لنا عن واحد بريطانيا
وواحد بالمانيا وواحد مش واقعي واذا بدك
تلمس الشباب حاول تجيب لهم قصه عشوها او
بعرفوها عشان هيك قصه الاربع دقايق اللي
اثرت فيهم ممكن ما تكونش اثرت فيكم ما
بتعرفوها او قصه شويه تاريخها بعيد لكن
الغريب انه زي هاي القصه صارت بالاردن قبل
تقريبا ثلاث سنين
بعام 2019
باعلان نتائج التوجيهي اجا الدكتور وليد
المعاني بالمؤتمر الصحفي المتخصص لاعلان
التوجيهي اعلن عن نسبه نجاح اعلن عن سعر
عمل الامتحانات والغريب وقتها انه اعلن عن
اول طالب اردني بجيب بالتوجيهي 100
متذكرينه اسمه احمد عثمان
حتى قديش كان في تعليقات عليه قديش انه
شاطر قديش انه قطاعه قديش
اولاد خالته راح يتغلبوا بالحياه قد ما
راح يتعايروا فيه اوكي بتذكر من تعليقات
انه هذا مش قطاعه هذا صندوق عده اوكي احمد
عثمان
احمد عثمان اللي سواه كنا حاطين حاجز وهمي
قدامنا كمجتمع انه ما حدا بيجيب ميه
بالميه بالتوجيه احمد عثمان خطا خطوه
صغيره للامام واثبت لنا انه هذا الحاجز
وهمي
مش الفكره باحمد عثمان الفكره بالسنه اللي
بعديها عام 2000 بالمؤتمر الصحفي تبع
التوجيهي
تتذكروا شو صار
بتتذكروا كم واحد جاب ميه بالميه
خليني احكي لكم قديش 78 واحد جاب 100%
مبهر
شخص واحد
تميز ثابر واجتهد والموضوع مش سهل واخذ
الريسك خطا خطوه صغيره للامام الهامت
اخرين بعديه بالسنه اللي بعديها حكوا اذا
احمد عثمان بيقدر انا بقدر
عشان هيك 78 واحد جاب 100% 71 واحد منهم
علمي بالمناسبه وسبعه ادبي كان هذا
الاعتقاد مش وارد زمان
على كل النجاح اصبح لا يكفي وقصه الاربع
دقائق زي ما حكيت لكم اللي قريتها قبل
اربع سنين كانت الها اثر كبير على الصعيد
الشخصي والصعيد العملي تشرفت قبل اربع
سنين بال 2019 بواحد سته 2019 باني ادير
منصه نحن انا وفريق عمل متميز
بتذكر باول اجتماعات لهم واحنا قاعدين مع
بعض احنا كنا بس خمسه ومعنا مدير حكيت لهم
قصه روجر
وحكيت لهم انه اطلاق منصه وطنيه للتطوع
وكلمه وطنيه ثقل على كتافنا لا يكفي انه
ننجح لا بل لازم نتميز
فحطينا المبادئ العامه تبعتنا وكل شوي كنا
نحط خط قلنا نقرر انه نتجاوزه
اذا بدنا نقدم اشي للشباب ونشجعهم للتطوع
لازم نقدم خدمات اكثر عشان هيك اليوم منصه
نحن بسبب فريق العمل وفي سبب الفلسفه اللي
حطيناها ببالنا انه النجاح لا يكفي لا بل
لازم نتميز وصل عدد المتطوعين 105 الف
متطوع على المنصه باقل من ثلاث سنين
[تصفيق]
جربنا على الثلاثه مليون ساعه تطوع منشوره
من خلال منصه نحن
تجاوزنا 350 فرصه تطوعيه منشوره من خلال
منصه نحن وكل هذا العمل تم من خلال فريق
عمل وشركائنا بالعمل التطوعي من مؤسسات
تطوعيه قطاع خاص مؤسسات مجتمع مدني وقطاع
عام مؤسسات اكاديميه جامعات وحتى مدارس
ونتجاوز عددهم ال 760 مره ثانيه يا شباب
النجاح خلوها ببالكم انه لا يكفي لازم
تبحثوا عن التميز كلياتكم فيكم القدره
انكم تتميزوا ولو مره ثانيه بخطوه صغيره
تتجاوزوا فيه حد وهمي حطيناه لانفسنا
وقلنا انه ما بنقدر
ابحثوا عن التميز فيكم لانه التميز هو
اللي بيصنع الحضارات وبقدم الدول بتخليها
تتقدم
فالحضاره تصنع من خلال المتميزين وبتمنى
كلياتكم تبحثوا عن التميز فيكم حتى تصنعوا
الحضاره شكرا جزيلا يعطيكم العافيه
[تصفيق]